i wouldn't call that a wealth tax but
it would help get at
capital gains which
are an extraordinarily large part of the
incomes of the wealthiest individuals
and
right now
escape taxation
until they're realized
treasury secretary janet yellen over the
weekend talking about this new proposal
for the pay for for this
administration proposal let's talk about
that and what's being debated on capitol
hill with utah republican senator former
republican presidential nominee mitt
romney senator thanks for being here
thanks brett good to be with you
first of all
before we get into the nitty-gritty and
the details here you know there's a lot
of optimism being projected by the
administration and democrats on the hill
where do you see these pieces of
legislation tonight at this time
well i think the democrats are pretty
desperate they want to get something
done for the president because he's kind
of circling the drain with the
electorate in the country and as a
result they're they're willing to do
almost anything i think so i think
you're going to see legislation passed
but the real problem is the legislation
is not popular with the american people
and it doesn't address the concerns
people have they're concerned about
inflation they're concerned about empty
shells and this legislation makes things
worse not better
now let's talk about this new pay for
structure it is a proposal to go after
unrealized capital gains some people are
calling it a wealth tax on about 700
billionaires
why in your opinion does this not work
well first of all it's not a good idea
to tell billionaires don't come to
america don't start your business here
to tell the steve jobs and the bill
gates and people like that this isn't
the place to begin your business go
somewhere else that's a bad idea but
number two you're going to tax people
not when they sell something but just
when they own it and the value goes up
and what that means is that people are
these multi-billionaires i can look and
say i don't want to invest in the stock
market because as that goes up i'm going
to get taxed so maybe i will instead
invest in a ranch or in paintings or
things that don't build jobs and create
a stronger economy
that kind of distortion of our economic
system is a bad idea for the entire
country because frankly we depend upon
people of means to invest in enterprises
to invest in the stock market that's one
of the reasons the stock market keeps
going up which is good for all of us the
idea that somehow there's somebody out
there that's going to give us stuff for
free it's just not going to work
you know
looking back at the alternative minimum
tax the amt when it was first created it
was going after a very small number of
people and then over the years it
expanded uh to roughly five million
people under amt is that what you see
potentially happening here
well that's of course one concern which
is not only will you convince
billionaires not to invest as much as
they have in the past in starting
businesses or starting investments in
the stock market but instead you'll have
more and more people that get hit with a
tax the idea of taxing people as the
value of something goes up
not when they sell it but just when the
value goes up that's a pretty dramatic
change and the unintended consequences
from that kind of change i don't think
the democrats have thought through and
whether it applies to 700 billionaires
or 700 000 americans ultimately the idea
of taxing people based on the value of
something going up suggests values will
keep going up what happens when they go
down are they going to get a refund
check are they going to get paid
interest uh for not having
had the benefit of their money during
the time when they were taxed when it
went up before
there's so many problems with a
dramatically new tax scheme that i don't
think the democrats have thought through
you know i i think it's a big mistake
you know i i know a lot of people
recognize that with nature everything is
connected and that if you change some
portion of our natural system why it
could have an impact throughout our
natural
environment well the same is true in the
economy when you change dramatically an
aspect of how we tax people you can
expect a lot of unintended consequences
and this new tax idea
is not a great idea in my opinion you
know the president keeps on saying that
this is not going to add a single dollar
to the national debt and this is all
going to be paid for even though the pay
force have changed dramatically in just
the past few days
you do a lot of reaching across the
aisle talking to democrats do you think
moderate democrats uh like the senators
mark warner like the maggie hassan's
like other senators are going to go for
this kind of big change on this issue
well i think they look and see that the
president's in trouble they see that
democrats generally are in trouble
politically
and and they're probably feeling a lot
of pressure to get something done
uh and there's some senators that say
they won't raise the regular tax rates
they want a new tax of some kind uh so
that they can uh if you will hold fast
to their original commitments
i think they're making a mistake to
raise taxes i think they're making a big
mistake to put in place a new tax scheme
they have could have a significant
impact in the economy and i also think
they're spending money in the wrong ways
look they're adding to inflation and
instead of dealing with something like
the emergence of china as a global
competitor we're going to be giving out
two years of free pre-k
this is not the answer to the problems
america faces right now so it's raising
taxes at a time we shouldn't and it's
also encouraging more inflation and it's
not addressing the real problems that
our country faces and that the american
people are concerned about you know uh
president obama went after you as a
republican nominee in 2012 on this issue
of taxes and and that you were paying
less than a nurse or a secretary and it
is the same
messaging that they're using today
here's senator dick durbin
but you ought to pay some taxes
if you can build rockets and take your
friends up for a little shot into space
should you pay a few bucks in taxes
i don't think it's unreasonable
same thing holds true for these
corporations when we look at the biggest
corporations and most profitable in
america too darn many of them pay no
federal taxes what's going on here
so is that attractive politically
senator well it's obviously been working
for the democrats for a long time and
it's simply just not true
which is that people
pay taxes and the higher income people
in america as you know pay a higher
share of their income and taxes as they
should as a matter of fact we're one of
the most progressive meaning one of the
most highly taxed high income people
in the world among our developed nations
and likewise our corporations all pay
taxes on their income they follow the
rules they report their income in the
way that's consistent with those rules
and they pay taxes if they have a profit
if they don't have a profit they don't
have a don't have a tax uh so these are
obviously diversionary things and and
the reality is that people are paying
their fair share if there's some people
getting around
the law somehow there's a loophole fix
the loophole but don't create a new tax
which is going to encourage high-income
people not to invest in starting
businesses
not to invest in the stock market not to
create more jobs here that is a serious
mistake last thing i want to read these
tweets from larry summers obviously
prominent democrats been in several
administrations uh talking about uh
inflation when the administration bid
administration formulated its budget in
february
it expected two percent inflation in
2021 i was warning about inflation their
forecast is no longer operative in may
and june secretary yellen expressed
confidence that inflation would be back
to the two percent range by late 2021 or
early 2022. now this forecast is no
longer operative he goes on to see
an interview secretary yellen asserts
twice that inflation has decelerated
this is a bit misleading
as the three-month and 12-month cpi
inflation rates are both around five
percent on an annual basis again
democrat larry summers just finally your
thoughts about inflation and where we
are as a country on that issue
well i think it's hard to predict what
inflation is going to do in the future
we're seeing it now and people are
seeing it the prices they pay for food
and for gasoline but 1.9 trillion
dollars that they buy administration put
out in january now asking for trillions
of dollars more i hope you understand
how much a trillion is a million seconds
ago it was early october a billion
seconds ago
george hubert walker bush was president
a trillion seconds ago
a trillion seconds ago neanderthals
walked the earth so a trillion is an
enormous amount of money and the
democrats i think are adding fuel to a
fire creating more inflation and it's
hurting the american people
senator mitt romney we appreciate your
time tonight thanks brad hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else